on the first day man was granted her
soul and with a clarity foreign man
great potential was seen yet
on the second day upon earth was planted
an irrevocable poison a soul devouring
demon form like the demon man had an
insatiable destructive appetite for
souls for power and so the scourge began
as God's two most terrible creations man
and their demons fought towards
extinction
you came for demon senses or to say this
Latin can be remembered as a hero no
problem
hunting for demons that is why you came
isn't it to this castle solitaire oh god
you see you've fallen for their tragic
in the dark state of our land legends
are all weak and dependable I refuse to
believe that this is what father wished
for
you have a heart of gold
let them take it from you surely you
have Sivan himself a pain suffering that
fills this world a faith poison of
poisoned God is merciful and so created
the old one your one who feeds our souls
and put an end to our tragic realm of
existence but perhaps our age will see
the rise of new heroes
near intent
the king you may be a great demon hunter
but I fear you may not be ready but
where the limits of your own power